a federal judge in Atlanta that's why
we're showing you the skyline there
since reality stars Todd and Julie
Chrisley to a combined 19 years in
prison yesterday after they were found
guilty of bank fraud and tax evasion now
the couple along with their children
spent nearly a decade on TV with their
series it was called Chrisley Knows Best
Building Wealth and a massive following
in the process Mark straussman is in
Atlanta with more on their story Mark
good morning I was just looking at the
picture of him with the Tiara I'm
wondering what was happening there mark
good morning to you
and good morning Gail Chrisley's Behind
Bars is the new reality for these
lifestyle Stars prosecutors say they're
career swindlers who built an Empire
jumping from one fraud scheme to another
I didn't sign up for all of this 21
years ago for nine Seasons the Chrisley
family entertained Millions with their
southern charm what are you doing I'm
making sure that y'all have the full
experience that your mother and I have
family drama
it's a very simple job do not let her
out of your sight oh my God and lavish
lifestyle what makes you think that you
can go out here and conquer the world in
real estate well you did but that
Designer world is over for reality show
parents Todd and Julie Chrisley they're
both Bound for federal prison taught for
12 years Julie for seven earlier this
summer The Chrisleys were convicted of
bank fraud and tax evasion the
Department of Justice argued that
Chrisley's falsified documents in order
to get more than 36 million dollars in
loans from local banks money they spent
on luxury cars real estate and travel
they then hid their reality show
earnings from the IRS after declaring
bankruptcy the sentences handed down
today by judge Ross or linthy they
reflect the magnitude of the criminal
scheme and in another setback for the
family just days before the sentencing
the Chrisley's youngest child 16 year
old Grayson was hospitalized seriously
injured in a car crash on a Tennessee
Highway his father detailed the accident
on their podcast christly confessions
last week I remember looking at Grayson
on that stretcher in the back of that
ambulance and him crying and all I could
think of was thank you God
because he's alive and crying the
reality TV series Chrisley Knows Best
followed the Georgia real estate
developer Todd his five children from
two marriages and his second wife Julie
they became the next Kardashian family
in a ratings Mega hit for the USA
Network if you're gonna be living here
and you gotta help me out daddy's not
paying for this anymore the show spawned
spin-offs like growing up Chrisley
starring children Chase and Savannah
I'll let you die that is just gonna kill
me I mean you got a point the outspoken
patriarch was set to host and executive
produce a speed dating show called love
limo scrapped after his conviction as
today's sentencing proves when you lie
cheat and steal Justice is blind to your
Fame for origin and position
prosecutors said the crystals deserved
even longer sentences for showing No
Remorse their accountant will also go to
prison we tried reaching out to the
Chrisley's lawyers without luck they
told us back in June they plan to appeal
Nate
mark thank you
wow the latest developments in that
relationship it just goes to show you
for people that love watching reality TV
that crime does not pay crime does not
pay and also reality isn't quite that
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true that's
true I mean they're going to appeal I
mean it is also a sad situation they've
got kids they've got family right A lot
of people are swept up in all this yeah
but I am fascinated guys by people who
are on reality TV that are apparently
doing stuff that is Shady or illegal
that you would put yourself out there in
such a public way because everybody's
watching yeah and I don't understand
that strategy and I don't understand the
multiple crime strategy if you're doing
the bank fraud why also the tax fraud
yeah like to pick one all that hiding in
plain sight